[موسيقى]
بوتا يقذف الرعب في قلوب البولنديين
اراضيكم كانت هديه من ستالين وبولندا يجن
جنونها وتتوعد بالرد وبقوه واولى نتائج
تعليق اتفاقيه الحبوب قلب اوكرانيا ومجلس
الامن يعقد جلسه طارئه والاضواء تتوجه
بكثافه نحو شبه جزيره القرم وزيرنس
ليعلنها كهدف عسكري مشروع فكيف سترد موسكو
واول ضحايا القذائف العنقوديه صحفي لوكاله
العالميه والكريم لن يتوعد بالانتقام زعيم
كوريا الشماليه يعلن عن مفاجاه عسكريه
وسيول تتاهب الدنمارك تتحالف مع السويد
والعرب في سبات عميق فمن ذا يدود عن
المقدسات الاسلاميه ونكايه بالصين سفينه
حربيه امريكيه تخدم في ميناء استرالي
بوصله بوتين تختار بولندا
السهام الروسيه تتعدى اوكرانيا وتصل
الحدود البولنديه وبولندا في ورطه غير
مسبوقه
حظها وتحرك الجيوش وتشاهد الاسلحه ليقولها
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على بلاطه
كما يقولها العرب اراضيكم كانت هديه من
ستالين بوتين وجه تحذيرا مرعبا لبولندا
بتصريحه هذا محذرا من مهاجمه بيلاروسيا
وكانه يقول نحن من اهديناكم ارضكم وان لم
تتراجعوا عن مخططاتكم فسنستعيد اراضينا
الغضب اشتعل في الاراضي الفولنديه لتستدعي
وارسو السفيره الروسي لديها وتحتاج على
تصريحات بوتين الاستفزازيه كما وصفتها
ليخرج رئيس الوزراء البولندي ماتيوس
مورفيتسكي ويرد على بوتين قائلا بان
ستالين كان مجرم حرب ومسؤولا عن من
البولنديين خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وبعدها بولندا لا تتوقف خشيه الخطر الروسي
وها هي تخطط لان تجعل جيشها الاكبر في
اوروبا باكملها ولتحقيق ذلك تعتزم زياده
الانفاق العسكري الى خمسه في المئه من
اجمالي الناتج المحلي ووقعت صفقات ضخمه
للحصول على اسلحه متطوره منها دبابه
ابرامز الامريكيه وطائرات اف 35 ومدافع
ودبابات من كوريا الجنوبيه لكن الا يعلم
البولنديون انهم بعيدون كل البعد عن
مقارعه روسيا بالسلاح مهما اشتروا من
اسلحه ودعونا نعود الى اوكرانيا حيث ظهرت
اولى نتائج تعليق العمل باتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب تطفو على السطح اذ اعلن وزير
السياسه الزراعيه والغذاء الاوكراني
نيكولايسولوسكي عن انخفاض صادرات بلاده من
الحبوب بحوالي الثلث مشيرا الى ان بعض
الشركات الاوكرانيه تحولت الى التصدير
باستخدام الشاحنات خطوط النقل بالسكك
الحديديه بعد وقف العمل باتفاقيه الحبوب
فيا له من وضع مؤسف يرفع خسائرك اكثر
فاكثر بينما عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه
طارئه لبحث تداعيه انسحاب روسيا من
اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب وحذرت اطراف خلال
الجلسه من خطر حدوث نزاع نتيجه لحادث
عسكري في البحر الاسود الخسائر ليست ماديه
فقط وها هو مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
يقر بان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
هجومها المضاد مضيفا انه مستمر رغم صعوبته
لقد قلنا انه سيكون صعبا ميدانيا اعلن
مدير المركز الصحفي لقوات فوسط الروسيه
اوليكتش يخوف ان السلاح الجوي الروسي دمر
10 تجمعات لقوتكاف وهنا تتوجه الاضواء
بكثافه لتصوب باتجاه شبه جزيره القرم وذلك
ضمن مجريات الحرب التي تعيد الى الواجهه
اهميه شبه الجزيره الاستراتيجيه وخاصه
بالنسبه لروسيا التي تعتبرها بوابتها نحو
المياه الدافئه في البحر الاسود ومنفذها
باتجاه مضيقي البوسفور والدار دانيل وصولا
الى البحر المتوسط لتعلن القوات
الاوكرانيه انها نفذت هجوما على مستودعي
اسلحه ونفط للجيش الروسي في شبه جزيره
القرم
بانفجارات مدويه ليتم اجراء جميع السكان
من المناطق المنتخبه للمستودع
داخلتك هذا لا بد من مصدر
الاوكرانيه انها نفذت هجوما على مستودعي
اسلحه
ونفط للجيش الروسي في شبه جزيره القرن
وكان حاكم القرم الموالي لروسيا اكد وقوع
الهجوم ما تسبب بوقوع انفجارات في
المستودع ليخرج الرئيس الاوكراني فلادي
[موسيقى]
يربط شبه الجزيره في روسيا يعد هدفا
عسكريا مشروعا مشيرا الى انه يجلب الحرب
وليس السلام وذلك بعد ايام من استهدافه
وتسجيل ضحايتين قبل استئناف حركه المرور
جزئيا به وهناك كشف زيلينسكي ان كياف
تقترب من لحظه تكثيف العمليات الهجوميه
المضاده الغضب الاوكراني فجرته كييف
باعاده الذخائر العنقوديه للواجهه في
الحرب مجددا حيث اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه مقتل الصحفي روسي تابع لوكاله
سبوتنيكل العالميه واصابه ثلاثه اخرين في
زابوريجيا اثر قصف اوكرانيا بذخائر
عنقوديه على المدينه من جانبه قال حاكم
مقاطعه بيل الروسيه بان اوكرانيا استهدفت
المقاطعه بمئه قذيفه بينها ثلاث قنابل
عنقوديه من نظام صواريخ متعدد الاطلاق
استخدام الذخائر العنقوديه جعل موسكو تخرج
ما في جعبتها من ذخائر مماثله كما تقول
التقارير وما علينا الا انتظار ان
يستخدمها الجيش الروسي في اقرب وقت كما
وعد بوتين في هذا الفيديو
الاحداث والتطورات
قالت هيئه الاركان المشتركه في كوريا
الجنوبيه ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت عده
صواريخ كروز على البحر الاصفر وشاء
الاطلاق بعد ثلاثه ايام من اطلاق جيشكم
صاروخين باليستيين في البحر الشرقي بحسب
بعد السويد متطرفون في الدنمارك يحرقون
نسخه من القران امام سفاره العراق في
كوبنهاجن لتدين وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه
واقعه الاساءه هذا للمصحف بينما شهدت
البلاد مظاهرات شعبيه حاول من خلالها
المحتجون الوصول الى مقر السفاره
الدنماركيه وان كان هذا هو رد العراق
المعتاد فماذا عن بقيه العرب
سيستمرو هؤلاء هكذا دون اجراءات راضعه
انطلقت في استراليا مناورات عسكريه ضخمه
بمشاركه 13 دوله وقوه يزيد قوامها على
ثلاثين الف جندي وعلقت واشنطن على
المناوره قائله انها رساله الى الصين
وتتزامن هذه المناورات مع تدريبات اخرى
تجريها الصين مع روسيا في بحر اليابان
وتضم حوالي عشر سفن وثلاثين طائره وخمس
سفن حربيه صينيه ينظر لها مراقبون على
انها محاوله لاستعاده نفوذ حلف وارسو من
جديد بدات الولايه المتحده تشغيل سفينه
حربيه في مدينه سيدني باستراليا وهي المره
الاولى التي تنضم فيها سفينه تابعه
للبحريه الامريكيه للخدمه في ميناء اجنبي
وذلك ردا على توسع الصين في المنطقه الى
السودان حيث اعلن الجيش السوداني مقتل 20
عنصرا من قوات الدعم السريع وتدمير اربعه
عربات قتاليه والاستيلاء على عربه اخرى
بكامل اعتادها بالاضافه الى اربع دراجات
ناريه بينما اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع
انضمام 15 ضابطا
و527 من الرتب الاخرى بالفرقه 20 لقواتها
في قطاع شرق درفار
[موسيقى]